i always felt like an outcast was
bullied my big goal in life was like i
want to be a best-selling author and
then it happens and
it really [ __ ] with me we're wired to
want status we're wired to want to be
beautiful and sexy and to want to
impress others like that's never going
to go away the question is is like what
do you want once that is kind of removed
from the equation you can always choose
in every moment to see things in a way
that that makes you feel better it's not
easy
it's actually really really hard but in
that sense happiness can be a choice
it's just a question of do you know how
to access it
[Music]
mark manson
the author of one of the best-selling
self-development books of the decade the
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] i read
this book many many years ago and i
learned so much from it so when they
told me
that mark manson was in london we got in
touch with him quickly and i think this
conversation is going to prove why he is
one of the most wise honest open
individuals i've ever met and one of the
most remarkable things he says in this
conversation was this smash hit book
which has sold more than 10
million copies and i know you've seen
everywhere
when that became a success
he lost orientation in his life mark's
complete story the story you've probably
never heard is immense he used to be a
pickup artist he then became an
entrepreneur which led him to become a
blogger which led him to become an
author and he draws on all of those
experiences and one of the most
self-aware ways i've ever seen on this
podcast to deliver actionable insights
to live a better life he's a guest that
you requested time and time again and
i'm so glad you did so without further
ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
mark take me back to
austin texas in the 1980s-ish
time when you were born oh god
what was life
what was life like for you
i mean when i was really young it was it
was nice
you know so i grew i grew up i had a
very kind of
conventional
suburban
[Music]
american childhood um
especially when i was younger you know
so
um i had the house with the yard and all
the kids on the street and
you know playing soccer and or football
or whatever
um
so so that was nice i think um
where things started to kind of
go off the rails so to speak
um when you know when you start hitting
that age 11 12 13 and you you start your
brain develops a little more and you you
start becoming a little bit more aware
of
um
norms and and culture and people's
expectations of you and things like that
um i grew up in a very i grew up in the
american south
so i grew up
very religious very conservative uh and
i'm neither of those things so
um
starting around that time i started kind
of feeling like an oddball you know
i was really into
art and music and
uh books i read all the time and
you know those values just weren't
really
respected a whole lot where i where i
came from in fact they were viewed as
suspects
i was going to say on the playground
that doesn't sound like it would be
conducive with fitting in and
yeah being part of the crew
yeah and it's um
yeah i mean it's a very it was a very
conformist culture but then there's also
there's a weird thing in the american
south
that
um
people are very sensitive to to kind of
like you know you think you're better
than me you think you're smarter you
think you're smart you think you're like
so good because you read this book and
you know got an a on that test or
whatever so there's like a weird like
it's actually very toxic but like
there's kind of a weird judgment that
happens
if you're not doing the same thing the
same way as everybody else
so yeah i i i started to kind of become
like the nerd slash uh like loner kid um
and this was the 90s so of course i wore
like band t-shirts and and
dressed in all black and like that's all
back in now yeah i know right
[Music]
thank god
i finally know what's going on again
i'm old enough to know what's going on
again um
so yeah it was it was a weird
adolescence it was uh it wasn't it
wasn't a ton of fun um
and i think by the time i was like 14 or
15 i was just like i gotta get out of
here i gotta i like i gotta get to one
of the coasts were you bullied in school
a little bit a little bit um not like
to a dramatic extent but
um
yeah definitely some like
shitty experiences for sure did you have
a lot of friends back then in school
um
no
no i i had a handful of like very very
close friends
you know other
other guys who were weirdos and loners
and in the music and
stuff like that
and your parental dynamics they were
your parents i read that they got
divorced when you were around that age
as well yeah
yeah
yeah i mean my parents are really good
people but um i would describe it now as
they were doing the best they could with
what they knew but
their knowledge wasn't
uh
i guess sufficient to be like fully
functional emotionally you know they
came from emotionally dysfunctional
families so in their head like giving
100
like they're giving 100 but really
they're 100 is actually kind of like
you know 40 50 of what
the family needed to like function well
is that psychologically or financially
do you mean like in terms of like
affection care lessons
it was
primarily emotionally so like
financially we were fine my my dad's
always been like very successful um
but it was it was it was mostly
emotionally right so
um i'm trying to think of an example
here you know so like kind of this idea
of
you know my parents were the opposite of
overbearing they were like
probably two hands off right so it was
like one of those things like if i had a
big event at school or uh a big moment
um or if like the girl i liked
was mean to me or something you know
it's like i could never go
to my mom or dad like if i tried to go
to my mom or dad and kind of like
express these things they just kind of
look at me like why are you telling me
this you know
so
it was a very
stoic and distant and i use the word
stoic not in the not in stoicism but
like
very kind of cold and distant household
like we didn't talk much and we
definitely didn't talk about
uh feelings or
insecurities or stuff that me or my
brother were going through it was just
kind of like
i can relate to that yeah
i never had i still think to this day
well maybe actually in the last year but
like my whole childhood my mum and dad
had no idea what i was doing with my
life no idea who i was dating feeling
nothing my dad like we didn't i don't
think we had a conversation about
anything to do with school feelings you
know so you kind of like you're like
left to your own devices and the
internet yeah to figure this stuff out
which isn't the best source when you're
like it's like solving solving the
problem with the same brain that got you
into it is not always the best yeah
solution when you zoom out on that
period of your life and you think
what what kind of like good or bad
foundations were laid from the rest of
my life what what are those lessons or
foundations that were like for me it was
like insecurity and i thought money
would be everything and i thought
validation from women would be
everything so you know
but
i think if there's one thing
my family got right when i was young it
was money so i grew up in with wealth
you know my my father
owns a plastics business he's been very
successful so i mean we we had the big
house and the pool and the nice cars and
everything and it was interesting
actually because his business really
started to take off
probably when i was like eight or nine
years old and so
we went from kind of like a
i'd say like uh upper middle class
when i was and then suddenly when i'm
nine it's like
everything gets upgraded you know we've
got bmws we've got
uh you know we're flying first class
like you know so we we get all the stuff
right right
and it
it's interesting because that's
pretty much exactly the time that my
parents marriage unraveled
and
you know the family kind of fell apart
so i learned at a very young age that
money doesn't solve it
like whatever your problem is
you know
unless your problem is you're hungry
like money's not gonna fix it so i was
very blessed in that regard that i got
to learn that lesson very early
um
so that that
you know we've all
we've all got that that that hole in us
that we try to fill with something um
and so money was never that for me for
me it was more i think because i was
i always felt like an outcast
um
was bullied
to a certain extent
uh rejected by like every girl i ever
liked for me was much more social you
know so it's like i had this desperate
need
to be liked
um
to be like the cool guy at the party
to have all the girlfriends
like that was my
my big weakness so you go off to college
would you study how does that go for you
in terms of social interactions
so one of the best things i ever did you
know i i went i went to school in boston
and boston's completely different
culture and environment um
and it's
it was wonderful for me because it it's
suddenly it's like the things i care
about are now
cared about by the people around me as
well so it's like they like that you're
smart and they like that you've read all
these books and they they like that
you're into like cool music or like some
obscure band
so it was very socially transformative
like i i went from kind of being like
the weirdo
nerdy guy to to like having tons of
friends and
going to a bunch of parties and
and having a really good social life and
so for me that was wonderful it built a
lot of confidence but of course like any
insecurity i overdid it
um so i was that guy who was
literally partying
five six nights a week
you know like for like year after year
you know i was i was always at the party
and did that compromise your academic
ambitions or uh a little bit um
you know i kind of i guess i didn't do
this consciously but i kind of made the
calculus in my head that like
like the most important thing about
college is that you
is that you finish you know right it's
like
no job interview is actually gonna ask
you what you got what grade you got on
your history exam
your second year uh all they care is
that you you have
you have the degree so in my head i'm
like as long as i get the degree as long
as like i'm safe
in terms of like actually finishing
um i'm okay so i i could kind of manage
okay grades well you know drinking every
night um
so i i made it work
and out of college your first job i i
heard you described it as kind of
nightmarish and like a finance jobby job
that you didn't like so i've had i've
had one
real job uh in my life um i went into
finance
uh so i used to play a lot of poker in
school and
uh and all the guys i played poker with
were gonna go into finance they wanted
to work on wall street and do all this
stuff and
i was like cool like i'll do that you
know
that just seemed like kind of like the
logical next step
and um i i got hired at an investment
bank in boston and i
went to work
and i remember it was like
it was 10 a.m on the first day i was
doing training
it was 10 am on the first day i'd been
there for like
maybe two hours two and a half hours and
i remember thinking to myself
how long do i have to stay here before
it's like
okay to quit
on the first day my first day and then
my second thought was
this is a really bad sign you know like
if i'm having this thought on my first
day this is a terrible sign so i lasted
about six weeks wow that was your first
and only yep
job yeah
i um
yeah i mean i i the corporate world and
i didn't really fit and and i've since
learned that that particular company
was kind of notorious in in the finance
world for for having like
a soul-destroying culture um
but it was funny because i you know i
was basically just like a
a data monkey you know it was entry
level so like i'm just punching numbers
in the spreadsheets and stuff all day
and uh
and there's this kind of awkward gap
in the u.s markets like there's like
an hour to
between when one market closes when like
the s p closes and then the nasdaq
closes like an hour hour and a half
later and so you'd always have this like
awkward hour where there was you're kind
of just waiting around waiting for the
next market to close so i'd bring books
you know
i'm i'm a book nerd so i'd sit there i'd
have a stack of books on my desk and i'd
sit there and i'd read books in that
hour and uh i remember my boss came by
and he's like you can't do that
i was like what do you mean i mean these
are like finance books too right like
i'm like yeah and he's like you can't do
that and i was i was like why not he's
like you need to be working on something
i was like what there's nothing to work
on like this is
waiting for the market to close and he's
like yeah but you can't you can't be
seen doing that like that's you gotta be
keep yourself busy i was like what the
[ __ ] man like
i remember too
uh my first week there
because i had messed around with like
some some computer coding and stuff in
college and and i noticed that like a
lot of the data entry that we were doing
you could easily program a script
to do it
automatically right it's like
probably an hour or two of my days like
not even necessary
and so i remember i went to my boss and
i was like i was like hey you realize
like we can get a script to do this
right like i could probably
you know spend a couple days figure out
do some research
and get it to work
and he was like
no no go back and put your numbers in
you know like he had no interest
whatsoever you know in my head i'm like
i got this great idea my boss is gonna
be so impressed i'm gonna like you know
get moved up or whatever and i i just
got shot down and so it was just very
clear like
um
i don't know it just wasn't there's a
cultural issue there isn't it because
your boss has probably got that from
somewhere above where he doesn't really
give a [ __ ] about optimizing the
efficiency of this company he just cares
about getting his check and then yeah it
probably trickles up the line yeah
yeah and i remember kind of like the so
one of one of the books i read at the
time was tim ferriss's four-hour work
week and uh
that book was life-changing for me but
it's funny i've always had a little bit
i've always given tim a little bit of
[ __ ] about it because
it was it was a bit of a double-edged
sword because the four-hour work week
makes it sound so easy
that it it kind of like
i remember at the time i'm like wow this
is
i could do that like i'll do that next
week like why am i still here you know
so it it's he made it sound so easy that
it kind of gave me the courage to quit
um but then of course after i quit and i
actually started to try to build a
business online and realized how
insanely hard it is i became a little
bit bitter of like damn you tim ferriss
this is not easy like
i'm never gonna work four hours
what was that business you tried to
build after you quit
so i uh i originally tried to create
some e-commerce businesses
and
try to
basically kind of your classic spammy
seo
blogs
with affiliate links and stuff like that
and
it was it was really like the whole goal
was like
just get to 2k a month and then we're
going to argentina like that was that
was the and then we're gonna party until
our
like our face falls off and that that
was the whole goal at the time i think
it was 22 or 23. and um
and it's funny because back then this is
like 2008 2009
back then uh
the way you got traffic to your like
blogging was new and kind of like the
big new thing and uh so if you wanted
traffic to your website to sell your
stuff you needed the blog yeah and so i
started my blogs
as a way to just get traffic to like
sell this stuff and so one of the
websites i i was doing was was a dating
advice and i was promoting
a bunch of dating ebooks written by a
bunch of people um and
and that that one started to take off
that one started to develop like a
really large audience and so after about
a year or two i realized i'm like i kind
of suck at this e-commerce thing but the
blogging is going really well so
and this kind of started your your
journey into the pickup artistry world
right so tell me about that because um
we before we started recording i shared
a secret that i've never shared before
which is that i also found myself
falling into the
pickup artistry world when i was in my
early 20s yep because of neil strauss
and then mystery and then every other
book that i read and every other video
and documentary and youtube video that i
consumed and torrent that i downloaded
and forum that i scraped um but when i
when i read that in your story i found
that really really fascinating because
um i suspected the incentives and the
appeal of that world were probably quite
similar to me in the sense of me being
quite insecure and um seeking uh
well yeah seeking validation from women
maybe yeah so tell me about your journey
into pickup artistry
i
took to it pretty pretty hard and pretty
quickly i think it really scratched that
that itch uh
that of that insecurity i had
you know from my childhood um
you know looking back on on the pickup
stuff
it's really interesting
and and it's funny because it's
over the years i've met so many talented
and successful guys like when you told
me that you were into it
i kind of i wasn't even surprised like
i've met so many talented successful
guys in the last five 10 years
who are like oh yeah i was i was i was i
was in that [ __ ] too you know it's like
we kind of like say it under our breath
and i think it it
here's my
theory about what what that whole thing
was and why it happened when i looked
back
in the 2000s
self-help and personal development was
still very different back then like it
wasn't socially acceptable
for men to
kind of get into
you know feelings and trauma and
and healing and recovery and all this
stuff like it was still it was still
something kind of shameful like your
your buddies would make fun of you for
it if they found out that you were like
if you went out and read um
you know like a louise hay book or uh
you know like i'm okay you're okay like
if like your buddy caught you with one
of those books in your bedroom
he'd start ripping on you for it and and
there was something about making it
about
dating sex and dating that made it
socially okay like it's it's now it's
like a cool thing to do but really what
it was it was just self-help in disguise
like most of it you know for every
pickup line or whatever there was like
there were
there was really useful advice about
uh you know social skills self-esteem uh
confidence
um
taking care of yourself you know hygiene
grooming you know and so there's like so
much good life advice there and then but
there was also so much bad advice there
too so it was this very mixed bag but i
think it was just a lot of guys like you
and me
who
were
were damaged essentially and we're
trying to to figure it out we're trying
to kind of heal ourselves
but there was no other outlet available
yeah um today it's it's okay i think
it's way more socially acceptable for
guys to be like yeah i want to work on
myself i want to like
you know it's cool now get in touch with
my feelings yeah and be a mature person
and and all this stuff yeah it's it's
like something people respect but back
then it
it was still taboo
and
specifically at that age for a guy
i'm speaking for myself here but i you
you're trying to figure out how to get
laid it feels like this this this quest
in which no one has ever provided you
with the blueprint or the road map and
then someone whispers in your ear at
some point that there's like a code yeah
like a simple solution to this complex
problem yeah and and then you read it
and you get into it and it appears to
work and you see men just like you
having success in that because they've
kind of learned the code or the the you
know they've been they've learned the
instruction manual so
it feels like it solves this tremendous
problem but you're totally right it
actually helps you resolve a ton of
things from the playground about
self-esteem and yeah why did that guy
always get the girls i didn't right like
the the natural and yeah and and then
things just started to make sense and
that made it really sticky and addictive
for me um
but you did you have were you in a
relationship around that time
uh i had a relationship yeah for
for a couple years around that time and
it ended badly
bad breakup uh
so so my first relationship pre-pickup
right ended horribly she ended up
cheating on me and leaving me for
another guy
and so that was part of
you know it was my first serious
girlfriend first love
and and it ended basically as badly as a
relationship can end
so i was heartbroken i was also angry
and so that kind of also
the pickup stuff really spoke to that of
like this is why you had your heart
broken um
this is what you need to do instead
how did that impact you because we're
talking here about like i think we're
talking about feelings of like rejection
and self-worth because i remember my
first
relationship that ended really badly the
harm was all me telling myself that i'm
not good enough and i'm a scumbag and
i'm maybe not pretty enough or smart
enough or masculine enough yeah and that
was all the harm it was inside here
um yeah it's it's funny because i look
back on that
episode of my life i i think if that
happened to me today i would
i would handle it fine i mean i'd be
upset obviously and hurt but i would
handle it
fine i i agree with you you know for me
when i look back
my understanding of
relationships love and relationships at
that time
uh i call it
the disney understanding you know it was
very naive it was
uh you know prince charming on the white
horse and you know the princess and you
live happily ever after right um it was
actually a very unhealthy relationship
she and i were both very
um
just very
dysfunctional and immature and we
treated each other poorly and but we
were in love and when you're that age
and you're naive like you think
love is the only thing that matters that
you're you you're willing to pretty much
tolerate
like any terrible treatment towards each
other because you're in love like it's
the level figure it out right and so i
think a lot of the pain for me
it wasn't just her leaving
like that was painful but it was also
having that kind of disney understanding
of love and relationships completely
shattered like everything i
because in my head i was like an amazing
boyfriend and i did everything right you
know so to have that blown up in my face
um
and and come that realization that like
everything i thought was true
is not
and i have no idea what's true
um like that's a really really hard
place to be and so that that was
probably at least 50 of the difficulty
as well is just trying to like pick up
the pieces and figure out like wait
you know how what is love what is a
relationship how are you supposed to be
towards each other i have no clue
but you have a clue now yeah
yeah i mean well and pickup was helpful
in that regard i mean pickup gave me a
lot of
bad
again there was a lot of bad advice but
there was a lot of good advice and
i think it's
look i i i think
people who
you know every once while you meet
somebody who who like
they marry their high school sweetheart
you know they meet when they're 14 they
get married and they live happily ever
like that is
it's very rare and people who if that
happens to somebody it's a very
fortunate thing i think for most of us
what we have to do is
is
you you go through
a number of relationships that just blow
up in your face and you have to have
them blow up in your face to understand
what's healthy what's not
what do you need as as a person and what
do you not need and also how
to give to others
relationships require a skill set and
you can't develop those skills like if
you if you're
if you come from a background like us
like you don't grow up being taught that
skill set like my parents didn't have
that skill set either so you have to
learn it through trial and error like
you learn anything else it just so
happens that the trial and error of
romantic relationships is
unbelievably painful
yeah so what are those those um
fundamental characteristics then of a
good relationship i've heard you write
about a few of them things like respect
and yeah what are those things that
you've come to learn now
that you wish you knew then i think
every you know every
healthy relationship with somebody else
it starts with a healthy relationship
with yourself right so if you don't
respect yourself
uh
and if you don't value your own
thoughts and well-being and health
you're never going to be able to set the
boundaries you know you're just going to
tolerate poor treatment from others
because you're going to think it's
justified so
you know people tend to have it
backwards they think like if i can just
find a great relationship then i'll feel
great about myself
but that's just it's a recipe for
disaster like you got to get straight
with yourself and then once you're
straight with yourself that enables you
to have that healthy relationship to be
able to share it with somebody else so
like
that's paramount
totally key like you got to get your own
[ __ ] straight you got to like whatever
baggage you got rummaging around up
there whatever trauma you've got in your
background
you got to start working on it
and then you need to be able to approach
the relationship with a certain amount
of vulnerability like you need to
you know again
most of us
by default
when we find that somebody that we're
crazy about or who's crazy about us our
our natural inclination is to start
hiding all the ugly stuff they're like
oh well if she doesn't know that like i
did this or if if i really like kind of
think that you know then she'll love me
it's like no you have to
come to the relationship completely open
saying like hey
here's my list of issues because we all
got them
um
i'm working on them because you're
working on yourself
you know hopefully we can work on them
together because obviously they're going
to have their issues too and so
just that open dialogue
is kind of necessary to even get things
started that's really where the trust
and respect comes from because like you
can't
like if you're not sharing
every aspect of yourself then you're
never going to trust the other person
like if you're always kind of hiding
something
you're never going to believe that they
are they're actually loving you they're
believing
the thing you're portraying to them and
so you're you're never going to trust it
you're like oh well yeah they're into me
now but it's because they don't know
about this thing over here
but if you just come
100
with everything on the table
that's where that's where the trust is
is you're able to start building the
trust and actually
you know start from a healthy place
so what you said at the start the first
point i i've i mean both points were
perfect but the first point really
it made me think about a million people
i know that are in the mindset that if
they can find a relationship it will
help fix their problems but they are
fundamentally like not ready for a
relationship so they go through this
like vicious negative reinforcing cycle
of like they weren't ready for a
relationship they got into one tolerated
toxic treatment smashed their
self-esteem even more which meant that
they were even less ready for a
relationship but meant that they wanted
one more because they they wanted to
fill the the crack in their self-esteem
with a person and you see them on this
this sort of like repeated rejection
cycle of these toxic relationships and
it's like going downwards because it's
smashing their self-esteem more and more
each time which is making them want a
relationship more and more but making
them less capable of having one and i
watch it play out on social media i'm
like jenny i'll make jenny stop i'm like
oh she's got another boyfriend
six months later i'm like oh no
yeah yeah yeah and and but because
social media what it's doing is jenny's
waking up in the morning and she's
seeing the car like kylie jenner looks
happy on that yacht with trap like with
her boyfriend and this so these happy
people in front of me are happy because
of their perfect relationships
and it's that awful spiral so to say to
someone
work on yourself yeah it feels it's like
well known
it's the equivalent of like
telling people who want to get a
six-pack to like eat vegetables
it's correct
but it's the last thing anybody wants it
it's like no no no no no give me the
secret five-day workout routine
you know it's like no there's there
isn't one yeah um
yeah it's interesting because
these things they work there's like a
they work in an upward cycle and in a
downward cycle you know and you just
described like the downward spiral uh
and but it also works the other way
around too because
once you're working on yourself and like
the work on yourself never ends right so
like once you are working on yourself
and you find somebody who's working on
themselves and you're able to
communicate about it
then you make each other better yes
which makes you feel even more confident
and and more proud of yourself and and
more
uh more solid in who you are which then
just enables you to work on yourself
even more and so it creates an upward
spiral as well like one way
i told a friend a couple years ago
because he was kind of having trouble he
was like you know i just
like you know our emotions blind us
right so it's like
getting in that new relationship like
falling for that person like it feels so
good and generally the way the way the
brain works is like when something feels
good we convince ourselves that it is
good and when something feels bad we
convince ourselves that it is bad so he
was like yeah it just it feels so good
that like i really think like
that that yeah we are being honest and
open and we are working on ourselves and
and uh and i think it's healthy and then
six months go by and it and i realized
that it's completely toxic and a
disaster
and so i told him i said you know the
the best way i can describe it is
when you're in a
an unhealthy relationship or a
relationship that's not quite working
right like you're you're not completely
being open or on the same page it feels
like pushing a boulder up a hill like
like you're always
pushing hard you know you feel like you
need to always be pushing to like kind
of keep things stable and in place
whereas
a healthy relationship it feels like
pushing a rock down a hill you know it's
like you just give a little bit bit of a
tug and it just goes
you know like you don't at some point it
doesn't even feel like you're putting
effort into it anymore i mean you are
working on it but it's like
every amount of effort that you put in
is immediately being matched by the
other person
and so it's like
you no longer you no longer feel like
you're just fighting constantly to like
keep things
stable
and you'll pick a partisan phase where
you learnt these lessons um eventually
you came out the other end as we all did
yeah my girlfriend's listening now we
all have come out
well
let it be known
but eventually you come out of it and um
you know you write you write about how
you realize that wasn't
a fulfilling long-term way to live yeah
just you know chasing women around
nightclubs trying to pick them up and
ultimately trying to sleep with them
right yeah when you slept with a lot of
women at this point um and you uh you
decided it wasn't the life for you no
what i started to realize
you know and this realization happened
on a number of dimensions around the
same time you know because because the
business started doing well and i
started traveling a lot you know there
generally anything
so in in in subtle art i talk about i
make a distinction between happiness and
highs
and
this distinction it was it was pretty
profound for me because
we tend to
we tend to mistake highs for happiness
right so
uh
meeting meeting an attractive person or
sleeping with an attractive person for
the first time that's a high
um making a bunch of money that's a high
uh having
you know winning an award or an accolade
or going to like some exotic vacation
putting on instagram getting a ton of
likes like that's a high and highs are
nice like we all we all love having
highs and and we we do need a certain
amount of highs in our life
but
highs are not happiness
happiness is actually
kind of the inversion of that in a lot
of ways happiness is
oftentimes actually unpleasant you know
happiness is
it's it's not the check that comes
you know
from the successful
product launch it's
the work that goes into that product
launch happiness is is the satisfaction
it's you know it's not like the peak
the super romantic date happiness is
being able to like sit at home on the
couch and not say anything and be
completely satisfied like it's
happiness is is actually
often very boring and so in my 20s you
know it started with women and parties
and then it kind of went to business you
know i wanted to grow a big successful
business and then i did that and i made
a bunch of money and then i traveled
around the world and i lived in all
these crazy exotic places and
um
and i started to realize that like the
these are just highs and the thing about
highs is that
the more you get
the more you need to get that same
feeling right so
if you've never left your home country
before that first trip is like
life-changing it's incredibly impactful
but if you've been to 50 countries going
to the 51st you're just like ugh
yeah that flight sucked like
you know like you're complaining about
the taxi driver like
you know because it's you need that much
more to get that same hit
um and so
it becomes a very dangerous thing to to
kind of
put all of your focus on these things
because of that diminishing returns it
takes more and more effort to kind of
achieve that same sense of satisfaction
or or
pleasure um
so i really started asking myself like
you know
what is
what are the things that i'm willing to
give up what you also don't realize is
that you're you're get you have to give
up a lot for those highs so like if you
do want to party all the time and sleep
with lots of people
you're giving up the opportunity to have
a stable relationship with somebody for
a long period of time you're giving up
uh the comfort that comes with that or
the security that comes with that if
you're traveling all the time and living
all over the world like you're giving up
the stability of a community of
uh
knowing your neighbors of
you know having
been able to see your friends
consistently like there's all these
subtle unsexy things that you're giving
up to chase the highs
that you don't really realize you're
giving them up until you've
given them up for a long time so i
started to realize that and kind of like
re
like rethink my whole understanding of
what
happiness and success is in general
so i'm i'm keen to get into the details
there but again jumping ahead a little
bit
is that a
well is that an easy thing to do
because because when you've got that
childhood force in you of like the
insecurities and the social acceptance
and that's always going to be in the in
you know and it can rear its ugly head
if you're if those kind of insecurities
are somewhat triggered as even as an
adult and it can say you know you need
to fit in you need to get by that thing
you need to travel you need to be more
successful but then you've got this new
set of like conscious values you're
describing where you're saying well i
value these things but then that little
demon on your shoulder is saying by the
[ __ ] lamborghini
well i think a lot of it is
you know i think a lot of value like
changing your values
and again i think i say this in subtle
art like you can't just sit on the couch
and think your way out of
your values like
you need to go live them and then have
them fail you
really and for me that that what that
looked like
you know going out and and kind of
living this fantasy life of partying all
around the world and hooking up with all
these girls
and then just having that fail me and
realize that it's actually very empty
and
uh and and realize after a few years
that you're you're literally not keeping
in touch with you know all these people
who you thought like oh my god we're
gonna be friends forever and then
three years go by and you realize you're
not keeping in touch with any of these
people and then you go on facebook and
you see like
that now they're married and they just
had a kid and they're so happy and
you're like [ __ ] i'm like still doing
the same thing like i'm still
drinking on a beach with the same people
um for like the third year straight like
something's not right here um
in the case of money it's like i think
sometimes people have to buy that
lamborghini and realize
it doesn't fix anything
like it's fun for a week or a month or
like you get to go show your friends or
your parents or whatever
and then they don't really care you're
so you're so right in what you said
earlier as well but linked to that point
is like i remember buying the big house
like seven bedroom house with a tennis
court yeah out in the countryside the
cost was i was now an hour and a half
away from my friends they couldn't come
anyway like yeah i was there for nine
months before i was like i said to the
landlord like please let me out
and i moved into this like one bed right
in the middle of the city because in
fact i'd exchanged like the status egos
i bought into the status and ego of
having this big house but the cost was
no one could come and see it yeah i was
lonely as [ __ ] it meant that my commute
to work was three hours there and back
it's like a terrible insecure decision
at 21 years old right so
and then but i had to do it like like
steve had to fight like taste that
himself and have it failed me as you say
so yeah
i know i'm jumping ahead again but
will's got a great story in his book um
so for context you wrote will smith yeah
brand new book called will yep
um
so will will had a hit record when he
was a senior in high school he was 17.
and of course
he went out and bought like four
different cars and a bunch of
motorcycles bought a house
and uh it was this great moment where he
he lined up all of his cars and
motorcycles outside his new house and
then invited his dad over and uh
his dad shows up
and he's like yo what's up pops like
what do you think you know and his dad's
like
are these all yours and he's like yeah
yeah yeah what do you think his dad goes
man what the [ __ ] are you doing you only
got one ass
what do you need four cars for
yes
and sure enough like two years later he
went broke you know exactly he spent all
his money yeah
he spent all of his money and didn't pay
taxes so that's a bad combination
damn you you really have you know and
it's i always think this because i've
read a lot of quotes and i've read a
book and stuff and i always say in my
writing like my words will never
overcome your insecurities yeah that
thing that kid said to you when you were
seven years old or your dad said to you
will always be a stronger force in your
life than some
140 character quote that i say about how
you should be living your life right
right go do the work right um
and learn that for yourself
why should you drink fuel we're going
into the fourth quarter of the year
diets are dropping off we're becoming
lazier and lazier and what tends to
happen when when our diets dip and we we
start to become less
compelled to go to the gym
is yeah we get out of shape we start to
feel low energy we start to binge eat
bad things and fuel is the antidote it's
nutritionally complete so you get
everything you need for your diet in a
drink you get your 20 grams of proteins
you're going to get your 26 vitamins and
vitamins and minerals
it's low sugar high in fiber it really
is the cure to a lot of the health
issues that we see in our personal lives
but in wider society if you've never
tried it all i'll ask you to do is give
it a try and if you like me then you
will like the world berry ready to drink
you'll like the mac and cheese which is
just selling like absolutely crazy
unsurprisingly um
you like the cinnamon
and you like the banana flavor those are
my recommendations i know a lot of
people love the chocolate flavor
let me know try it get yourself healthy
and send me a message on instagram tag
me on instagram as well on your stories
if you do try it out because i sometimes
upload those tags
and let me know which is your favorite
flavor can't wait to hear from you
one of the things you say is um that
your one rule for life is each person
must never be treated only as a means to
some other end but must also be treated
as an end to themselves yeah
please tell me what that means
it's a little it's a little
philosophical it actually comes from
from
the philosopher kant um
it basically means that like
i think anything that is
is
unethical or unhealthy
it's because we're not we're treating
another person as a means to another end
right so
if you're
kind of using somebody for their money
or if you're manipulating somebody to
try to like get a job or a promotion or
something
or if you're just straight up like
stealing from somebody or lying to them
like in all of those cases you're tr
you're valuing
some external thing whether it's money
or a car or prestige more than the
person themselves
and
i
to me it's just kind of like
when i look at every
useful piece of advice whether in
personal development
or
just how to be a good person you know
how to be an ethical person it all comes
right back down to that rule like you
everything you do it needs to be
ultimately for the betterment of
yourself or others like making yourself
a better person
and making other people better too
and anytime you deviate from that
you're either going to
get into ethical trouble
or you're going to get into
toxic relationships like if i've got a
car that i'm selling and i know that
it's faulty yeah but i invite someone
over and i say this is the best car in
the world please buy it
it's unethical and you're you're using
that person as a means to an end in a
personal development context it's like
if you're dating somebody not really
because you like them but because you
want to impress your friends
then you're using that person as a means
to some other end right and it's like
that relationship is going to go south
really fast like it's going to get ugly
so
it's not just ethical it's practical you
know kant minute like said it in ethical
terms but i just kind of realized that
it's like
all good personal development advice is
essentially the same thing it's like
treat people well like put place people
before
money before
you know accolades before
attention or status like always put
people first
and uh
and everything else kind of takes care
of itself and that's the long-term game
right that's the the it's because in the
short term you might sell the car yeah
but in the long term your reputational
damage and your general sense of feeling
inside and yeah
which which you see all the time in in
internet businesses right like it's you
see kind of those
sleazy sales letters
that that are pushing a questionable
product
and sure maybe they they have a big like
five million dollar launch
but they've just completely destroyed
you know eventually all those people who
bought are gonna realize that the
product is [ __ ] and they're never gonna
buy from you again
and so
you've yeah you made a bun millions of
dollars up front but you've completely
destroyed your brand and you're gonna
have to start over from scratch
whereas
if you kind of start with the people in
mind
and you focus on the good product the
good relationship giving people good
value
you make less money up front but then
those people stick with you
forever product after product after
product
um
i was watching your conversation with
tom bill you and i found it really
really
interesting and important because one of
the things you talk about when we're
talking about you know deciding what you
want to do with your life whether it's a
business or you want to be a pickup
artist or whatever it is is this the
importance of asking the question why
and in the society and culture we live
in especially one that's so driven by
comparison where your values are almost
being handed to you by instagram and the
kardashians like this is how this is
what you should value
like i almost i've almost felt i
remember one day a kid came up to me
after i did this like big talk on stage
and he said i want to be a public
speaker
and he was like 17.
and you're thinking but you've got
nothing
really what he's saying is like he
doesn't want to be a public speaker he
wants the admiration he thinks public
speakers get probably because he's
insecure yeah and
and
so many kids including myself as a young
kid
we don't actually know what we want we
have no [ __ ] clue but what we
probably want is not to be insecure and
heart of it and get laid
of that as you've described takes us
down a dark alley to the wrong place
usually a dead end as well so how do i
figure out
what what i actually want in my life
without it being kardashian noise or
instagram like what does what do i want
and how do i find out
i think
so it's a tricky thing right because
again i think you you kind of have to
get it wrong it's like the relationships
you need to get a couple wrong before
you know how to get it right and i think
it's the same in
pursuing a career or or finding a
purpose in life like you you need to get
it wrong a couple times because
we're experts at tricking ourselves you
know it's like that kid he wants
admiration right
but if you ask them in his head he's
like no no i'm just really passionate
about communicating with people i love
people you know it's like
we all do that to ourselves we all like
we find the
admirable narrative to kind of explain
what were
what we want in the world so i think you
need to go through
you need to hit a couple dead ends you
know it's like that kid he probably
should go get on stage and
give the speeches and get the applause
and then realize that the applause
doesn't solve anything that he's he's
still just as insecure as he was before
because then once once he does that then
he'll be ready to ask that question of
like why do i want to do that like why
am i really doing this
it's almost a question you have to earn
in a lot of ways interesting you know
and i feel like a lot of people they
just want to start there
and it's like no no you have to like
because look we're all like the
kardashian thing right like
like the reason that stuff is so popular
is because
we're wired to value it we're wired to
want status we're wired to want to be
beautiful and sexy and we're wired to
want to impress others like that's never
going to go away the question is is like
what do you want
once that is kind of removed from the
equation
but i think mentally to be able to
remove it from the equation you have to
try to get some of it first and and and
see that it doesn't work
if that makes sense and what did you
come to learn for yourself um once you
got that stuff you had the money you
were you know had lots of um success in
the field yeah with uh pick artistry and
you tried all of these things and you
tried the cars and what did you come to
learn that you value
well i had an interesting
experience
in my career which we were joking about
it before we went live was like i kind
of had this realization so i started
the pickup stuff when i was like 21 22.
and and then i started coaching and like
teaching dating advice
um
probably when i was like 23 24.
and i got to like my late 20s and i it
suddenly it started to dawn on me that
like
this is cool now
but
in like five years it's gonna be really
creepy you know like it's it's one thing
to be a 25 year old who's like taking a
bunch of dudes out to like talk to girls
in a club
it's very different to be like a 35 year
old guy
who's taken out a bunch of dudes to talk
to 20 year old girls at a club like it's
just it's a much different look and i
also just realized i'm like i don't want
to do this forever like this is fun but
like i this is actually not fulfilling
in any way whatsoever like i need to
find
what my next thing is going to be and
during that period when i was
doing all the dating relationship advice
i started to realize especially like a
lot of a lot of clients a lot of guys
who hired me
you know i take them out to the bar and
we talk to some girls or whatever
but
after a year or two i realized like what
these guys really need is a therapist
[Music]
you know it's it's their problem you
know they're good guys like they're
they're smart they're they're like
they've got a good job
um
they're sure they're a little bit
nervous talking to a girl but like who
isn't
what really what their most of their
problems were is like very deep-seated
insecurities emotional issues and they
hadn't dealt with it yet
and so
the last couple of years i did that job
i would kind of just take the guys to
the bar
as an excuse
and then sit down with them and be like
okay let's like what's really going on
in your life you know like like let's
get into
why do you feel so
insufficient or or unworthy of
you know dating her or talking to her or
whatever and so i kind of realized that
like you know what i should be writing
about is this stuff
you know the the like
the the three best first dates or like
how to get her to reply to your text
every time like i was writing stuff like
that back then because it got traffic
and it it it would get sales but i'm
like
that's not what people actually need
that's not what they need to hear what
they need to hear is kind of this deeper
stuff
about self-esteem and self-worth and
vulnerability and
and so i i made that decision to pivot
into that to stop being the dating coach
and and and actually start writing about
personal development and emotional
health because that's something i knew i
could be proud of and and i could do
for the rest of my life you know you you
can be a 50 year old uh talking about
those things and it's still like
something you can hang your hat on like
but i never would have gotten there if i
hadn't done the dating coach stuff if i
hadn't kind of been obsessed with the
like yeah let's go to the club and like
try to get laid like you that's the
entry point right and then you find the
deeper stuff along the way
and that's your that's your sort of now
your professional um
value i guess the one of the things you
value professionally but in terms of
like holistically when you look at your
whole life one of the things where
the values at the heart of
mark that allow him to be
you know fulfilled stable and uh
yes states
sus
like the sustainable values that you
think can last you because of these
values i will be
somewhat you know content and fulfilled
for the next 30 40 years holistically
gotcha
so i mean the answer is going to sound
really banal but like um but it's true
uh
you know i think probably the biggest
one for me is is honesty and not just
honesty
you know with the
with the people in my life like honesty
is a standard that i hold kind of
everybody all my friends and everybody i
work with too
but it's also something i hold myself to
uh being honest with myself
i think generosity is is one that i've
discovered
again it's one of those things that when
you do make all the money like you do
make a butt load of money
you learn that it's so much more fun to
spend it on other people than it is
yourself like it feels so much better
and and it means a lot more like it's
it creates those really powerful moments
that you you do remember for the rest of
your life whereas the lamborghini you
forget about
[Music]
22 seats right yeah
um community is an interesting one that
you talk about often
having a community something that i
disregarded when i was pursuing just
becoming rich myself was yes
connection and it wasn't it was actually
i think a ted talk i saw where the ted
talk was was telling me that men who
have been in a relationship and had
strong relationships live longer are
healthier are happier and i was thinking
what you know like because it was a
counter narrative to my like just be be
rich you know yeah thing
yeah i mean community was one that i
had to kind of like
begrudgingly accept same yeah um
because i always have been such a loner
right and and and it
i think living abroad for for so long it
kind of forced me to accept
my own loneliness you know and and
recognize and i was
i started achieving a lot of great
things in my business and having all
these great experiences and then
realizing that like nobody i really
cared about was around me when it was
happening and so it felt
to a certain degree it felt kind of
pointless so i moved back to the states
and and settled down and
and one of you know one of my
goals when i moved back to the u.s was
like i want to have a stable group of
friends who are kind of on the same path
as me
and it's
yeah it's one of the best things i did
honestly
you referenced honesty a second ago
which i find really um another really
interesting one it's uh so when you said
honesty what i understood was um being
honest about who i am what i feel what i
think what i'm passionate about and
um stubbornly and unnegotiably
protecting
my right
to be my true self in life and um
that again it allows a lot of the the
toxic insecure stuff to fall away and
just wear what you want be who you are
etc etc um how important has that been
for you in terms of just like being your
true self every day of your life and
um is there any tips or tricks you have
for especially someone like you who's in
high demand and there's lots of people
asking you to do lots of things and be
lots of things and yeah how do you
defend that
above all
honesty first of all you can't be your
true self without honesty like if you're
not being honest with yourself and about
what you want and what you care about
you're not being your true self like
you're you're deluding yourself and you
know a huge cornerstone of my work in
general is just
all the ways we delude ourselves because
we delude ourselves in a lot of
different ways so to me it's it's a
constant work in progress it's it's um
it's almost like a mental habit that you
build uh one you know one of the tools
is what you mentioned earlier is like
constantly asking why you know it's like
why why am i taking this job why am i
saying yes to the speaking opportunity
why do i want
to write email newsletters or why do i
want to build my instagram following
like really why you know and
try on different answers like always try
on the answer you don't want to hear
and see how it feels see if it feels
true or not
kind of coming back to the community
point
when you do find some some like-minded
people like people who are also kind of
dedicated to honesty and being
being self-aware
they can be great sounding boards i mean
my wife is always the first one
to tell me when i'm full of [ __ ]
which is great you know obviously i
don't like hearing it in the moment
sometimes but you know sometimes i'll
tell her something and she'll be like
are you sure about
you sure about that you know she'll kind
of like start challenging me challenging
me on it and um
you know and i've learned to
to to um to take that well and and take
it seriously
um so that's kind of the first part is
like it's something you you continue to
cultivate throughout your life um
your second question was was about
bringing that honesty kind of into the
world especially
dealing
in business dealings and
people who ask things
and
it's hard like
it's interesting because
i wrote about this in a newsletter once
it's like when you're starting out you
you kind of have to say yes to
everything like it's like you're
desperate for opportunity and so you're
just always saying yes yes yes
and then a weird like
transition happens at some point where
you you have to start saying no to
people um or else you're just gonna lose
your mind um because there's just way
more opportunities than you can ever
handle and so you have to like learning
to say no
gracefully i think is
a very important skill
uh in business and in life
like being able to like let people down
and
in the business context
actually in the personal context as well
i what i've kind of found to be like the
easiest way to do it
is i kind of create rules for myself
uh
and i don't know what it is but when you
tell people i have a rule
and this is why i'm saying no
they take it really well like they
actually respect it you know so it's
like if somebody comes to me and they're
like hey i've got this event this like
charity event
uh it's gonna happen this month you know
would really love if you're able to like
do a video for us or come out or
whatever and it's like you know i really
don't want to do it if i'm just like hey
sorry but no
you know like
then it starts to feel really weird and
emotional and possible yeah they if
exactly it feels personal yeah i think
that's what it is um because
and they started they're like oh no but
like we really want you and like the
kids are gonna love it and blah blah and
then you start you're like god i'm a
horrible person and yeah you know and
they're like they're kind of thinking
i'm like wow mark manson's an [ __ ]
yeah yeah and
but if i go to them and i'm like look
like
my rule is i do four events a year i'm
already booked i'm sorry
then it was the principle that let them
down as opposed to the you know you yeah
exactly and they're like oh man i should
have emailed sooner
he wants to do it but the principal said
yeah but it's but it's true it's like
i'm not lying it's just i create a rule
for myself you know another thing
another rule uh
and it was a really popular article i
did is is is a
uh if it's not a [ __ ] yes it's a no and
so what i've learned is that
a lot of times turning people down i'll
say like look i have a rule for myself
you know i
if i'm gonna do something i need to be a
[ __ ] yes about it like i need to be all
in
and 100 like
dedicated to it and i said i'm not
feeling that with this i wouldn't be
able to give it my full energy and
attention that and and it deserves that
so i'm gonna say no
you know and so when you put it that way
they're like
huh good guy mark manson like looking
out for me you know
uh so it's there's like um
i think there's there's some some tactic
they're like good and bad ways to say no
to people um
one of the other things that i really
loved when i was reading all of your
work is this undercurrent of personal
responsibility yeah that runs through
everything and in our society for
whatever reason people don't like that
some people yeah really don't like that
idea of personal responsibility that you
might be
more so than you believe responsible for
the circumstances of your life because
for some people that shines that turns
the mirror on them and says you've got
no one to blame sure it's not the
government it's not this that this your
uncle whatever it's the decisions you've
made and for some people that's a
motivating thing it's liberation it's oh
i'm in control okay
but it feels like some people would
rather there be a puppet master to point
to um yeah so
what's your beliefs and thoughts on
personal responsibility the importance
of it and
if you can as well um like why some
people hate it
i think uh
to me responsibility is kind of like the
the core
understand like if if there's no
personal responsibility nothing else is
ever gonna work or improve you know to
improve anything you have to
believe you have some sort of power
influence on it and if you have some
sort of power influence
you're responsible for that power and
influence so if you if you just reject
the idea that you're responsible for an
area of your life like if it's like i'm
not responsible for my shitty
relationships it's all their fault
you're basically disempowering yourself
from ever improving them because you're
you're rejecting the idea that you have
any influence on them
i think i think the reason
or one reason why people
really kind of bristle at the idea is
i think we we tend to mistake
responsibility and fault
right so
if if i
if i'm like a typical dumb american and
walk right across the street in london
looking the wrong way
and i get hit by a car you know it's not
my fault
that i got hit by a car
but it's still my responsibility like i
still need to
take take control of my recovery i need
to like
take care of my body i need to decide
you know
what i'm going to do
there's a per there's a responsibility
in every moment because in every moment
we're choosing
what to do
[Music]
what to perceive what to believe
what to focus on like that choice is
happening every single moment
and because that is a choice
there's responsibility for that choice
right
um i use the example in subtle art of
like
if somebody left a newborn baby on your
doorstep
it's not your fault that there's a baby
on your doorstep
but it sure [ __ ] is your responsibility
like you have to do something
yeah you can't just shut the door and be
like not my baby
like it just doesn't work that way and
so i think
particularly people who have had a lot
of bad things happen in their life
and and those things are not their fault
it's very very difficult for them to to
accept responsibility
because well for a couple reasons one is
it's once you accept responsibility it
means you have to do something
you have to change something you have to
change your perspective you have to
change your actions you have to change
your beliefs and
all of those things are very
uncomfortable
but i i think the other thing is that a
lot of times people get very attached to
their stories right so
a terrible thing happens to them
it kind of [ __ ] them up
and that becomes their identity like
that's how they get sympathy from other
people
it's how it's how other people know them
it's the basis of a lot of their
relationships and so they're actually
afraid to let it go right like it's it's
actually a scary thing
to
to let go of that identity
so yeah it's it's a hard thing to do but
we all have to kind of go through that
struggle
it's really interesting
it's a yeah
it's something that i see a lot in in
our in our culture at the moment
specifically with young people because i
think instagram has
um created more of a community for that
kind of like i'm going to just be honest
that kind of like self-pitying and blame
um and the algorithms are now kind of
reinforcing that and you know you'll get
more likes if you do the yes it's you
know
i i i heard it referred to as the
victimhood olympics yes exactly yeah
yeah
which is like oh you win
you've had the worst [ __ ] happening
here's your medal one of the kind of
self-development
you know tropes or like you know piece
of advice i hear often that's linked to
that is that happiness is a choice
how do you feel about that phrase
uh
i mean i think it's fundamentally true
obviously i think it's a little more
complicated than that um
but it kind of comes back to what i was
saying like
you i think when people say that what
they're referring to is like in every
moment you get to choose what to focus
on right so
if a car hits me in the middle of the
street here
i can either focus on how unlucky i am
and how unfair this is and how it
[ __ ] up my
press trip to
the uk you know and all this stuff
you know or i can focus on something
else i can focus on
you know how fortunate i am to survive
how you know and i think this is where
kind of like the the positive thinking
stuff was intended
to refer to you know like classic
self-help of like just think positive
like this is what it what it was trying
to say but it kind of got distorted and
turned into this weird delusional thing
but it's basically like you know in
every single moment you are choosing how
to see things and so in that sense you
can always choose in every moment to see
things
in a way that that makes you feel better
and
it's not easy it's actually really
really hard but in that sense happiness
can be a choice like it's
it's always within your power there's no
person on earth that the happiness has
been removed from their brain like it's
it's all in there it's all in you it's
just a question of
do you know how to access it
and will you access it will you choose
to
and one of the things that does feel
like a choice link to that is the
expectations that we we choose for life
and you write about how expectations can
really be a
a curse of happiness yeah um
how do we so why are expect are our
expectations a potential curse and why
are they dangerous and how do we set
better expectations then
well expectations are dangerous because
uh you know i think there's a i forget
who came up with it but i think it's
there's this like old equation where
it's like
happiness equals reality minus
expectations you know so if you have
these like huge unreasonable
expectations for yourself you're always
going to be disappointed but then it's a
double-edged sword because if you have
like tiny expectations for yourself then
you're not going to try to do anything
so like there there's this weird balance
where
i mean i i prefer kind of like more the
buddhist take which is like just don't
have expectations like just don't expect
anything is that possible
no but
but it's kind of like honesty right like
it's it's you
you never completely get there but you
should still try
and um
it's and it's particularly useful i find
in in
managing anxiety you know because
anxiety tends to
come from
uh
just either irrational or outsized
expectations right so it's like you're
about to go on stage and talk to a bunch
of people and your expectation is like
i'm gonna bomb i'm gonna look like a
fool like people gonna laugh at me and
it's because of that expectation that
you start feeling a lot of anxiety start
feeling terrible whereas if you just
kind of take the expectation of of you
know
this is just another
moment
you know it's it's going to happen
people are probably not going to
remember it
like it just is it's going to be
whatever it's going to be
um
it can eliminate a lot of that i do that
with with my book launches because
obviously like any author i'm like
i probably was probably the same with
you like you know that when your book is
coming out like you're like crippled on
the floor like everybody's gonna hate me
they're all gonna laugh at me you know
and it's
to me it just helps to just remove any
assumption of like what it's gonna be
you know don't assume it's gonna do well
but don't assume it's gonna do poorly
like it's it's gonna do what it's gonna
do and you're gonna be fine either way
so
even though you know that
do you still feel
of course
of course like you never
the anxiety never goes away but it gets
managed right
do you suffer with anxiety uh yeah for
sure and how long have you suffered with
it for
i mean sounds forever i mean i am human
yeah
so there's it's kind of like a i see it
well i see it as a spectrum almost
there's like
on one end of it it might be and i'm if
i sound super naive here it's because i
am like um there might be
nervousness before you know pre
pre-performance anxiety and then there's
like the daily struggle with
anxiety which can be like debilitating
yeah i guess
yeah i think the way most people look at
emotions they look at emotions in terms
of intensity and i think that's not the
right way to look at it like it's
everybody feels anxiety it doesn't
matter like the most confident person on
the planet feels anxiety it's what's
different between somebody who
seems very confident and somebody who
seems to debilitated is that the person
who seems confident
is managing their anxiety very well
they're they're channeling the anxiety
very effectively into their actions and
behaviors whereas the person who's
debilitated by it is not
so in that sense i see
managing emotions it's like a skill
right and and and i think this
we all kind of know this like we all we
all know somebody who's like very good
at managing
their anger or somebody who's very good
at managing their anxiety and we all
probably know somebody who's very bad at
managing their anger
somebody who's very bad at managing
their anxiety or managing their sadness
and so i think it's you know so
we each kind of have like a natural
talent for some emotions and not others
and so it's something we kind of have to
learn like you you learn to
feel the anxiety
and then use that energy
you know
kind of adopt the right mindsets and
beliefs around it and then use that
energy in a way that's effective
you write about you know how
especially in everything is [ __ ] a
book about hope
how
mental health
ailments are somewhat increasing in the
world it appears it appears
some people say that it's because we're
like you know diagnosed over diagnosis
yeah or whatever but um i would assert
if i was to be to guess and based on the
information that i've seen and i'm a big
um
heavily involved in a company called a
tie life sciences which is in the
psychedelic space so we look at
schizophrenia and depression and anxiety
um it does appear to be increasing
people do appear to be getting more
anxious and my general belief which is
not backed by anything is that how could
we not be in a world that where there's
so much stimulation yeah if you go back
to you know our tribal tribal roots
versus today it's just constant so
anxiety and thinking about the future
and depression and these things are
probably increasing um you talk about
how
a lack of something to strive for
is at the root cause of a lot of this
and how as life has got more
comfortable
um
we've got into trouble
yeah
there's you know so a lot of that book
revolved around
kind of this interesting paradox like
there seems to be a very very subtle
trade-off
between
comfort and meaning
and
kind of a very simple example is like if
you imagine
if you remember like back like 100 years
ago right like
most of the population is living on
farms there's wars going on all the time
there's diseases all the time it's very
easy to know what to hope for it's very
easy to know what gives your life
meaning like you got to get the food
harvested for next season like you got
to feed
you know your eight kids or whatever
whatever it is or you got to survive the
war
and so
these kind of existential questions of
like what is my purpose and like what am
i here to do and am i using my talents
the most effectively like these don't
even enter into the equation like it's
just pure survival
and it's kind of what i was referring to
either like earlier that that
that why question is almost a privilege
like you you almost earn it right and i
think
our society has become so affluent and
comfortable
that
we're starting at that why question
right so it's it's if you're a young
person today
you've grown up with this incredible
technology you have access
to all of the information in the world
um
you're more educated than anybody in
human history
you
if you are fortunate enough to go to
university like you're going to have
tons and tons of career opportunities
and job opportunities so this question
of like who am i
why am i why am i here on earth what am
i meant to do
is this the best use of my time like
these are really [ __ ] hard questions
to answer and we're hitting people with
them when they're like 16 17.
so it to me it makes sense like it and
to me it's like
it's a very silent cost
of our affluence and comfort mm-hmm
makes perfect sense to me
just in my own life i think one of the
most um
dis i've talked about this before one of
the most destabilizing disorientating
moments of my life was when i was i had
financial freedom yeah and in fact it
was on the day where someone offered me
financial freedom so it was when someone
offered to buy my company and i talk
about this i go home and i'm sat here
and then i'm thinking but then what like
i'm going to give up my like because i
was i was trying to i was trying to make
it yeah survive like and someone comes
along and says we'll give you x
tens of millions
and
you know i'm 25 and i'm thinking but
then what am i going to do with my life
and i'm trading off my purpose for this
big pile of cash which isn't going to
give me purpose
so um
that
i had a bit of an existential crisis
there um figuring out what
what my actual why was and i didn't
think it was much i felt like life was
much easier before that
when my clear maslovian objectives were
like food water shelter not
self-actualization yeah that's a really
crazy thing that when you make people
comfortable and free you give them
an essential crisis
yeah yeah
you like trade
physical hardship for
emotional mental hardship
and uh and obviously i think most of us
would choose the emotional mental
hardship over the physical hardship uh
but it's funny i mean i had a very
similar experience after subtle art took
off um
you know i had massive royalty checks
start coming in and
you know for like 10 years before that
my big goal in life was like i want to
be a bestselling author i want to like i
want to be one of the most popular
authors and bloggers in the world you
know and then it happens
and all this money shows up
and
it really [ __ ] with me and it's funny
because i've talked about this in a few
interviews and
um
and it usually like they have no idea
what i'm talking like it's one of those
things like you feel like such an ass
for saying it talking about it because
it's people just like yeah
yeah [ __ ] you like yeah yeah
like i'll take that problem any day but
it's true but it's um anti-climax
miserable
yeah i just honestly i just kind of sat
on the couch and played a lot of video
games because i'm like well what now
like
any book i write is not gonna
you know so that's not super exciting um
all like
grinding on my internet business which i
had been doing for seven or eight years
up to that point it's like suddenly like
i've got more money than i ever expected
so it's like
okay i don't need to grind that hard
anymore um
so what do i do like what
what am i really doing again it comes
back to like earning that why like i
really had to ask like
what am i really doing this for like i
obviously i i believe in the message of
the book and everything but
again like like you you kind of alluded
to like when you're coming up
it's
it's very exciting and it's very it's
very easy to know what you're gunning
for like you've got the north star yeah
orientation and you've got nothing to
lose right you know it's like
it's like business fails
whatever like i was i started broke i'll
be broke again like you know like let's
make it happen but then once you get
there
and you're like [ __ ] i got
an i've got contracts i've got an agent
i've got an audience i've got a team
suddenly like it's
there's a lot to lose and it's in it and
it
and it becomes uh it becomes a lot
harder to know like what are you gunning
for you know like what are you
what's the next mountaintop is that a
low moment for you psychologically
strangely yeah yeah i i actually the
the year after subtle art came out was
probably the most depressed i've been
since i was a teenager
um
and yeah it's
you know there were a few people in my
life that i could talk to about it and
and and understood um but so here's the
funny thing
again you feel like such an ass like
it's like you're literally experiencing
the most success of your entire career
and you feel so aimless and lost and i
remember
the first person i came across i've got
a friend in new york who was the
co-founder of a unicorn startup
and uh
and i remember he was the first person i
mentioned it to and he was like well
yeah of course
you know and he's like every every
founder
has this like it happens all the time
um and then the the other group of
people that i found that understood uh i
did some
podcasts with uh
some famous comedians
and and every single one of them was
like of course dude like every comedian
who gets their first special
they're like the year after is like
the worst year of their life
i completely get it i struggled with
understanding why
am i ungrateful
but that's really fascinating i don't
think
it's not something that i
i knew about you but it's of course if
i'd really thought about it i would have
been able to guess that that wouldn't
have been
yeah it's i think part of it too is the
velocity of success yeah um
i think if it
if it had happened more gradually
because like my online business right
like my online business
basically grew like 10 20 a year
for like eight years straight so it
ended up
being a
making a lot of money
but it was each year was like 20 better
than the last year so it's like my mind
had time to adjust but then this comes
along
and suddenly suddenly you're like
you know 500 exam or 200 x in
whatever you were at before
and uh and like your brain just can't
keep up like it's
how did you
like recalibrate and come out the other
end and how did you kind of readjust
your thinking to say okay we're gonna
strive for things now we know that it
might not reach the meteoric success of
this but there's another
you know set of foundations that way
it's funny um so the the the next book
everything is [ __ ]
was very much motivated by all this you
know so so it's the core thesis that we
just talked about everything is [ __ ]
is like what is it about
being comfortable
and affluent that like [ __ ] with you oh
yeah
makes us so like neurotic you know uh
and it's because i was going through
that so that it's like
i've always written the books that i
need to read
um
and so everything is [ __ ] was exactly
kind of what i needed to read there's a
lot of like just subtle mental
adjustments you know again like
realizing that i can say no to a lot of
this stuff like it took me like a year
or two to realize like i don't have to
accept all these speaking gigs like you
know i'm tired i'm like i'm exhausted
like i don't have to say yes i don't
need the money like you could start
saying no to this stuff
um you know that it took a while for
that to sink in and then and then kind
of finding another why you know like i i
think for me it was
it was uh
you know so much of my identity
and i i actually didn't realize this
until the pandemic um but like
so much of my identity was kind of
wrapped up
in like
being the upstart internet blogger
who's kind of like
you know overcoming you know
somehow overcomes the odds and becomes
this huge best-selling author like a big
part of my identity was wrapped up in
that and i realized that that holding on
to that was not helpful it was actually
kind of
that was a big part of what was making
me miserable and so letting go of that
and just kind of accepting like
okay i'm an author now
but you know maybe i won't be forever or
yeah i'm an internet entrepreneur but
maybe i won't be forever like you know
it doesn't you're not your label exactly
like i i can go
do anything that i want like i'm not
like beholden to this
narrow lane that i lived in for so long
um and so kind of coming to that
realization was it was actually
very very helpful so two points there
then you talked about finding your new
why
coming out of that and the other point
was about
learning to say no let's start first
then with learning how to say no
you're in a phase of your life now where
you're between projects yep right um
you've been working very hard for a long
period of time as you said before we
start recording six years
and so so how do you fall so six years
of working very very hard
your projects have been ticked off
obviously you're in the uk on your press
run will's books coming out which you've
just written
so
how does how do you approach switching
off and that phase of being in between
work you know in a culture and amongst a
narrative where you should always be
climbing and working or yeah for some
reason that feels like it's connected to
our sense of worth right in society if
we're we're not working we're not
striving
yeah i i think
so the kind of that that hustle culture
right like
i think there is value in that like i'm
extremely grateful that i
did learn the work really really hard
like ridiculously hard i think that's a
very valuable life skill and
for people who are young or starting out
or starting their business like i think
it's
incredibly valuable to learn that and
and to cultivate that
but i think kind of what i've discovered
the last year or two is like there's a
lot of value in also learning how to
find the off switch
because
it's very easy to kind of become
compulsive about work and and also
develop kind of a
this irrational belief that like if you
stop it's all going to disappear you
know it's like oh if i take a week off
like
all the traffic's going to go away and
the book sales are going to stop and
it's completely irrational but like it's
when you're caught up in that
that constant hustling and striving like
that that's what it feels like
to me it's it's i i finally hit a point
about midway through this year that i
had no major project like the wheel book
was done
i just did a documentary in new zealand
like that like all the shooting for that
was done
and then my next book
isn't due to harper for another year or
two and originally i was going to start
writing that immediately but then i took
a couple weeks off and i'm like oh my
god this is so good like
this is so good
and so i decided to kind of just take
the rest of the year off um
from any major project and and and just
kind of basically work kind of part-time
and manage my my online team and
um
and it's been wonderful like it's and
it's the world doesn't collapse and it's
it's been so
recharging for me not just like in terms
of energy but
creativity um and then also kind of this
identity piece that i was referring to
like it's only by getting distance from
something that you're able to
disidentify from it like you know when
if you're working on something 12 hours
a day you're gonna identify with it like
it's impossible not to but then when you
pull back you're actually able to sit
there and kind of ask yourself like do i
want to be an author forever do i want
to have an internet business forever uh
do i want to go
you know
do i want to start doing more celebrity
memoirs do i want to
try to work in film like what do i want
to do like what's the next why and i
think this is like a really important
point that doesn't get talked about
enough is that like you're wha like
there's not
this
this predetermined why out there that
just exists forever like your why is
always changing you know my why when i
was 25 was get laid make money and get
laid
and uh you know and then my why in in my
30s was was you know become a big author
and super successful and get a lot of
attention and accolades and and i'm
realizing that like my why in my 40s is
probably going to be something else and
that's not only is that okay but that's
actually exciting now
i don't know
i don't know um suspicions
i really i really so here's the thing
after subtle art i i kind of lost my why
but i freaked out like it it terrified
me um because
i think i was still in that mindset of
like this could go away at any moment
and you know and
now i'm at a place where i'm like no no
like i'm good
you know it helps that the book is still
selling really well you know four or
five years later the wheel book is doing
super well you know so it's like i'm
good like this
phase of my career is solidified
and as soon as i kind of like became
confident in that
the why question went from being scary
to just exciting it's like i get to go
play
like i can just screw around like i can
spend a week just like screwing around
with crypto and like
nobody
could tell me not to like it's it's and
it's like is this a thing i don't know
maybe it will be maybe it won't you know
or i can um i can screw around with like
with a screenplay i feel like i'm like a
kid in a sandbox you know so interesting
that you've got to that point where you
can have
freedom without a sense of
meaninglessness yeah
whereas
which is really interesting
and maybe that's because you have got
some projects in the future you do have
a book coming up i do have another book
yeah um but i'm trying to understand
what what what's got you to the place
where you can now have the freedom
without it being disorientating and
i think the thing that changed
honestly is
the confidence
that i can do it again
you know it's
i think one of my deep-seated fears when
subtle art blew up was like this is a
fluke i got lucky so as a result of that
so much of my motivation was like don't
lose it right like
keep fighting keep posting online keep
writing newsletters
keep the books coming like promote the
[ __ ] out of them you know we don't want
to lose this and then
i think i i kind of hit a point where
i'm like
i don't need to fight for it anymore
like it it's it's not going to go away
you know i earned it it's going to stick
around
i don't need the fight for this forever
this is going and so and then once that
happened yeah i just it stopped being
about
trying to hold on to what i have and it
became much more of just like oh there's
a freedom here
you know and i could go do some amazing
stuff especially now i have resources
and connections and all this stuff like
i like
there are a lot of great opportunities
that could happen
in front of me and so now it now it's
it's actually just excitement
um
yeah so we just have a tradition the
previous guest leaves a question for the
next guest okay our last guest wrote
for you yeah what is your favorite quote
my favorite quote is from david foster
wallace he said you'll stop worrying so
much what other people think of you when
you realize how seldom they do
it's kind of dark but also liberating
and it requires an explanation because
it's so interlinked what we've been
talking about thank you so much for your
time today your books have been i'm so
refreshing in this space because they're
so real
they're so um
multifaceted and nuanced and they
present a different perspective on
self-help and personal development which
is not often um
uh not often conveyed in a lot of the
books that i've read so your book i
think was just so your the subtle art
book was such a smash hit because it was
so
um refreshingly uniquely
um challenging in so many fundamental
ways and your next book is actually my
favorite your book after that about hope
and about meaning was so
from the the narratives that we share
was so on the money for me because it
answered a lot of those fundamental
questions about meaning and the need for
struggle which again people in our
society don't appreciate the need for
struggle the work you're doing is
amazing and your new book with will um
is is more of the same and i can't wait
to to get stuck into that book as well
thank you for for your time today
honestly you're one of the people in my
life that i genuinely were so excited
about meeting because because of those
um common narratives and yeah you're
doing a real service to our society so
thank you thank you appreciate that
thanks
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast me and my team use that as an
indication of whether the episode is
good or not based on how many new
followers and subscribers we get thank
you so much
[Music]
you